le quartier des minguettes à vénissieux
dans la banlieue de lyon est en tournée
bully ces violents incidents ont opposé
la nuit dernière deux jeunes maghrébins
aux forces de l'ordre
un policier a été grièvement blessé
ainsi que le porte parole des jeunes
maghreb vient d'une quartier gérard la
nuit dernière vers 2 heures du matin les
policiers prennent en chasse une voiture
conduite par des jeunes gens le
conducteur a grillé plusieurs feux
rouges au départ donc une prise
classique n'a pas retiré les policiers
les jeunes des minguettes non plus du
tout la même version pour les policiers
l'un des gardiens de la paix s'est
retrouvé entouré est frappé par une
vingtaine de jeunes armés de barres de
fer et il a tiré pour se défendre
du côté des gens on affirme au contraire
que le policier a lancé son chien sur
des genres trois autres garçons sont à
leur arrivée le coup de feu evasio six
de pau qui reçoit ce soir les jeunes des
minguettes ont refusé de continuer à
participer au projet de démolition des
deux autres tours un projet qui
expliquait il ya quelques jours tout
michel qu'est ce qu'ils font là les
jeunes avaient ces travaux ont abouti à
quoi on a commencé une tour s'est fait
beaucoup de choses hein ça soit cuit les
ferrailles que ce soit bois alors on
récupère tout ça et on y revint à des
casseurs
ça va un peu d'argent du secrétaire est
ce qu'ils vont en faire de cet argent
bah notre projet à nous la
c'est les envoyant laborde alan woods en
2000 c'est à dire avant les vacances
d'été
oui c'est à dire si ce serait pas comme
l'été précédent ça serait pas un autre
qui paierait les vacances et j'ai un peu
trop souvent là ils gagnent leurs
vacances eux mêmes